it's nice to meet you what's up bro tell  me please why you think you're qualified  for this position i'm not  well do you have any experience nope do  you have any experience with microsoft  sure  shut your mouth i'm on tick-tock and i  expect you to pay me a living wage  your resume is just a piece of paper  that says i go pee pee and poo in my  pants and would you call that  professional i'd call it accurate you  are the worst interview i've ever had do  i get the job sadly  yes  because of the state of our society and  the government  i've been forced to hire this man who  clearly has [ __ ] his pants  he's been walking around in it all day  he smells like [ __ ]  [Music]